الحياه الاجتماعيه والدينيه قبل تاسيس
الدوله السعوديه الاولى يمكن ان اجزها لك
بما يلي
الدين الاسلامي موجود وهناك من يلتزم
بتطبيق الشرائع وهناك من لا يلتزم والصوره
التي ضخمها الباحث العربي ابن بشر بان
الحياه الاجتماعيه يسودها
حاله من الكفر والفقر والجهل والبدع
عباده ليست بذلك المستوى
الاساس في نشوء الدوله السعوديه الاولى هو
حاجه المجتمع في نجد
والجزيره العربيه الى تحقيق حكم سياسي
مركزي يقوم على فرض الامن وخاصه امن قوافل
الحج والتجاره والسابله والسابله الماره
في خاصه قوافل قوافل الاحساء الماره
بالعارض والمتجه الى مكه والمدينه وهذه
المهمه التي
ركز عليها الامام محمد بن سعود ليست وليده
اللحظه انذاك بل اجداده من قبله كانوا
يقومون بهذه المهمه
الامير مانع الامريكي او ابنه
موسى او ابراهيم ابن موسى
بن ربيعه حيث بينت وثيقه ايضا من كنوز
الارشيف العثماني ان الدوله العثمانيه
خاطبت حاكم الاحساء بتكريم عده اشخاص من
امراء نجد منهم الامير
ابراهيم بن موسى المريدي حاكم وامير
الدرعيه الذي كان يقوم انا ذاك بحفظ امن
قوافل الحج ورعايه افرادها وتسهيل مهمتهم
بالوصول الى الاماكن المقدسه ايضا حفظ
وسلامه عودتهم الى ديارهم الام يعني وثيقه
عثمانيه تكشف عن دور جد الاسره ابراهيم
ابن موسى بانه احد الاساسيين الذين او
حاكم الدرعي حاكم الدرعيه اولا وانه مسؤول
عن التمرين وهذه الوثيقه توسع بشرحها
الاستاذ الدكتور راشد بن محمد شاكر في
كتابه وقديم اعتقد ان تتكلم عن تاريخ
قديمه 981 تاريخها يعني قبل محمد بن سعود
بزمن بزمن كبير